[موسيقى
] ربما ضرب الوباء بانكوك
لستة أشخاص ، لكنه لم يدمر
روحها ، فالديك يطن
ليس من أجل لا شيء هو المكان المعروف
باسم مدينة الملائكة
السماوية ليلاً
، كانت بانكوك وتايلاند في التسعينيات من
بين النمور الآسيوية الأصلية  انظر
إلى هذا المنظر جيدًا
، ثم سكت النمر ثم صمت
، فقام وعاد للنوم
الآن بانكوك هي من بين أولى المدن
في جنوب شرق آسيا التي أعيد فتحها بشكل صحيح
خلال كوبي ، كانت
هذه الزيارة قبل وصول omicron ،
حيث
تلتقي الروحانية والصفاء  الفوضى والاضطراب
رغم كل ما هو ناجح
، فهذه هي سحر
[الموسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الأمر برؤية الأجزاء الشهيرة
من
بانكوك والقصور والمعابد وما شابه ذلك ،
فهناك طريقة واحدة حقيقية للتجول
في واحدة من هذه التوك توك أوه  أنا أعلم ما
الذي تفكر فيه في البحث عن توك توك ، ما هو
مبتذل ولكن أعدك
في واحدة من هذه أنني سأشاهد المزيد من
رحلات [الموسيقى] في بانكوك كثيرًا ما ينتهي بها الأمر
بلحظات تذوق رائعة
لهذا الصبي  y هي مؤسسة طهي هنا
في بانكوك
j5
لوصف طبخها لأن طعام الشارع
يشبه إلى حد ما
استدعاء رولز رويس مجرد سيارة
لها عجة السلطعون ، يأتي الناس جيدًا
لأميال لتجربتها بما في ذلك نفسي
إنها جيدة جدًا ومعروفة لديها الآن
نجمة ميشلين
لا تتحدث الإنجليزية ، وحتى
مع الترجمة
، لن تتحدث إلينا مشغولة جدًا بصنع
العجة ، ربما سأجعلها
تعطيني موجة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] ضآلة جاي  فاي التي تقف شامخة
فريدة من نوعها في قبعة أحمر الشفاه ذات اللون الأحمر اللامع
ونظارات التزلج ذات العلامات التجارية التي تحمي
عينيها من تلك الساعات الطويلة أمام
الحرارة الشديدة ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، يا إلهي ،
فقط كمية كبيرة من
البروتين السلطعون داخل
كمية ضخمة
كان الطعام أكثر من جيد
ولكن الآن  قيل لهم للخروج أنهم
بحاجة إلى طاولة ، هناك قائمة انتظار بالخارج ،
هذا هو السعر
الشائع لطعام شارع ميشلين ستار
من ملكة طعام الشارع إلى ملكة حقيقية
أتقنت مطبخ القصر
[موسيقى]
إنها كوانتيب ديفاكو  لا هذا
مطبخ تايلاندي تقليدي
معروف باسم الشيف بوم وهي
تعرض لي شوربة توم يم غونغ الأصلية
، أول عشب في توم يم
هو
عندما تقول اسم هذا الشيء ،
أشعر دائمًا أنك توم يم ، وأنا أعلم
أنك قلت  أنت على وشك مهاجمتي ، حسنًا ،
إذا تعلمت التايلاندية معي ،
فسيكون واضحًا
أنك صارم جدًا
وجهك ،
يجب عليك اتباع تعليماتي في
المطبخ لأن هذه منطقتى
ترى
أنه لا يوجد أطباء مسؤولين هنا ،
نعم  أخبرني عن ثقافة تناول
الطعام التايلاندي الذي لا نأكله في الدورات ،
كل شخص لديه طبق أرز خاص
به ونتشارك جميع الأطباق معًا في
الهند دائمًا نستخدم جمبري النهر ،
هل هذا
ضخم للغاية سنقوم
بتقشير القشرة
هنا  في بانكوك ،
ما الذي يمكن أن تقوله هو الجانب المحدد
لما هو طعام الطهي ،
فأنا مستعد للاستماع أو أخذ أي
ثقافة طعام من الشمال من الشمال
الشرقي من الجنوب ويمكنني
مزجها في وجبة واحدة في
طعامي  يعني أه
نحن كرماء  لذلك أضع رأسك
هناك ، فإن
خلفيتك مختلفة جدًا
لأنك أتيت من الطبقة الأرستقراطية ،
فأنت نجمة تلفزيونية ،
أنت طاهٍ عامل ، ثم قطعت
إجازة الليمون
من أنت ،
فأنا مجرد
امرأة عادية
لدي شعار أنه
إذا  يجب أن أعمل ،
يجب أن أفعل
أي شيء
أحبه وأحاول أن أفعل أفضل ما في ذلك ،
ورائحة طيبة مذهلة ، نعم مدهش ،
أنت لست امرأة عادية ، أنت
متخصص في مطبخ القصر ،
جدي يمكننا أن نقول إن الأمير على
حق وأنا '  لقد نشأت معه ،
أنا محظوظ ، لديّ جدتي التي أعدت
الطعام لجدي في عصرنا
وأمي
تحب الطهي ،
أنا سعيد بطبخك ،
ما أواجهه
هنا مختلف تمامًا عن الطعام التايلاندي الذي
أحصل عليه  في المنزل حيث طعم كل شيء بصراحة هو
نفسه ،
أعتقد أن المخزون جاهز
للأطعمة
المختلطة بعناية والمختلطة ،
إنه بعيد كل البعد عن طبق
الدجاج التايلاندي الغربي أو الكاري الأخضر ، وهذا
هو السمة المميزة للعديد من أمسيات
السبت بالخارج ، إنه لأمر رائع أن
ترى أن
توم يم قد انتهى  إذا كنت ترغب في تجربة
wo
هذا هو اللذيذ الأصيل والأصلي ،
فإن مذاق الطعام التايلاندي معقد للغاية ،
إنه متوازن جيدًا في وجبة واحدة
الآن
هو أنه مثل
الشعب التايلاندي
نعم وعندما نطبخ
يمكنني القول إننا نطبخ من القلب
[موسيقى]